hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lam waifu and today i
am the one
here to tell you that gone has returned
and that the whole point of the series
sort of came to a head
with gone finding his father isn't it
great let's get into it
the entire series has been predicated on
gone managing to find his dad
he wanted to know everything about him
he wanted to know why his dad wanted to
be a hunter and he wanted to speak to
that hunter
dad father hunter father while episode
146 is going to be quite the doozy
episode 145
was a clear and pleasant not that the
outcome was expected but the sequence of
events that got us
there would not and i think that's where
the cleverness of the ark lies because
frankly as far as i can tell
everything else that happened in the arc
was entirely unnecessary detail
unless something more comes up now four
episodes out considering this is the arc
in which gon finds his father and i
don't know if it was the final planned
arc because i know tagashi is known for
hiatuses
i'm surprised the ark was so short and
has been so avoidant of that central
tension between father and son
it's not that i expected jing to go see
gone it's not that i expected gon to go
see jing in he's been in a state of
mummification until literally this
episode
and you know it makes sense that i would
feel this disconnect but also it doesn't
make sense really we've so rarely had
insight into god's feelings why would we
have insight into his father's why would
jing be more expressive of his thoughts
than gone
because he's kite's mentor that doesn't
seem likely besides gone is now a little
kid
no not gone as little kid gone is always
a little kid kite is now a little kid
besides kite is now a little kid goodbye
to that arc i guess
and while i really should spend more
time prevaricating over the actual
voting and discussing the tension
between
paris and ratman and his papa friend i
feel like that's pretty self-explanatory
we know paris and should win
because leorio's reason for wanting to
win is gone
periston was able to read jing just as
well as jin could read him both earlier
and when gon was healed and
we don't know at this point whether it
was a ruse but it's also the closest
we've ever come in this series to jing
showing care for his son
however small and insignificant so we'll
take it right there's an interesting
observation to be made about the fact
that a lot of the room knew that
something happened but no one said
anything about it
and even more to be said about the fact
that jing didn't move in response to it
the way jing
has behaved about gone to date suggests
that he knew the state of his son he
knew why it had happened and
maybe he'd even sent the person to try
to heal him but that it hadn't worked
i think it's also interesting that in
all of what's happened jing probably
kept a close eye on how his son
progressed because if
jing has been on the association's board
this whole time
he's been a part of the entire
development of his son which raises
another question for me
why didn't gon just look at the names of
the people on the board he clearly could
have done so the entire time and didn't
which
if as someone on twitter suggested the
reason the show is called hunter hunter
is because gone is hunting for jing thus
hunting hunter
gone is an awful hunter because would
you not use the resources at your
disposal to find what you're hunting the
most surprising thing to me about this
episode and in fact the most surprising
thing to me about the entire arc thus
far is the fact that alaka
actively has an attitude towards
something
which is to say alako commented on the
fact that something was not her
it's almost as though there's a
symbiotic relationship between the two
in the same body and the most
interesting thing we learned was not
just that there was an attitude between
the two but that the same attitude
seemed to hold across them
the fact that alaka has largely not been
there tells you how hands-off all the
other characters have been towards her
and how afraid they've potentially been
about invoking something or bringing
something into the room
and that's the first actively
interesting thing to me this arc
it's also the thing that explained why
it's so important that kilwa
specifically is there for alaka
and that kiwa plans to be with alaka
forever one thing i didn't understand
about this episode was subone's
musings on kilwa subuni thinking keel
wise heartless and cruel is an
observation i wouldn't have made based
on what i've seen of him
and i wonder whether it was born of the
fact that he plans to make sure
something stays asleep and alaka gets to
live or the fact that he's got his own
brand of toxicity that's about to come
in
once he's made this wish for gone and i
suppose there's no way to know that yet
because the story needs to progress a
little bit more to get to it but making
the observation that when he was being
controlled he suffered less suggests
that the heartlessness and cruelty he's
showing is to himself that being
controlled there was greater
self-preservation and maybe that's
really what it is
in a family of assassins catching
feelings of any kind is going to limit
the quality or effectiveness or
willingness to do your job
and maybe that's what subuni's seeing
more than anything there's so much to
consider with the little murder boy and
i suspect i'll be thinking of him for
some time
artistically before i move on to the
next episode there were some beautiful
choices made
the romance of tension and held moments
for leorio despite
us knowing it's gone the images of
everyone around him and the clear and
open
beauty of leorio's feelings toward the
kid were heartwarming to say the least
anyway moving on to episode 146 as
predicted
episode 146 was a doozy a familial doozy
no less
turns out i was wrong in 145 both with
alaka and something's pronouns and in
the understanding of them and i really
like that
i love having my expectations messed
with i love surprises and the complexity
involved with alaka and something
is one that had more subtle detail than
i expected
at this point in the art in fact at this
point in the show i guess
it's not so much that we were treated to
new information that would contribute to
a
need for more information we were given
some closure which is very
untogashi-like closure was something i
feel like we first experienced with the
ants but even then we didn't get
complete closure
we knew that the world kept turning that
things kept happening and that we would
expect to feel discomfort again
soon with this situation it's not that
the world is a better place it's not
that illumi is going to be less of a
zoldic it's that he was going to look
after his sibling
and that in itself is really beautiful
but more we learned that alaka isn't
simply being carried along for the ride
alaka and something are compatible
symbiotes i guess
they're friends they care for each other
and while something was the one
with powerful men or magic i kind of
feel like it is here
it's with alaka's blessing and awareness
that it's used
and that's really quite important
anything that something is alaka
is accepting of similarly anything alaka
is
something appreciates kiawap trying to
protect his sibling in that case became
a good
question of which sibling he was
protecting and maybe speaks to what
subuni was talking about in terms of
being cruel because he understood what
something was trying to do
and who something was by sending
something away kilwa knew he was dooming
something to an
unhappy existence but he didn't know how
much he was hurting alaka by doing that
because between them
alaka something and kilwa are all the
emotionally connected members of the
family or so we thought for his mum to
rescind the control she put on him
she had to have heard the situation that
unfolded and choose to respond in an
emotionally supportive way
which is an interesting development
because i remember his dad way way back
seeming to assume that kilwa would come
around and come home eventually and just
be a good good little assassin
all these familial dynamics have been
great to see in their own way and while
there's a huge
element of found family or seemingly
found family particularly with leorio's
influence and the way hisoka's tacked
onto the zoldick family
though he suspiciously disappeared the
found family elements are a really
enjoyable aspect of shows and anime like
this because a family you choose is
going to have a more powerful
influence than the family you're bound
to if that makes sense not more
important
necessarily but more powerful because of
the explicit consent involved in
choosing who you engage with
choosing who you trust choosing who you
love and care for that's why we love a
found family narrative
especially when we look at them side by
side like this gone wakes up and leorio
immediately dives for him immediately
shows his love and care and how afraid
he was to lose his friend
gone looks at the power his friend could
wield and the story that took
shape in the first arc knowing how
important being able to help people was
to leyorio became
important here at the end with gon very
simply saying no
he shouldn't be here he wants to be a
doctor which not a single person asked
and even leorio because he wants to help
people
probably wouldn't have thought about his
own desires because he's a carer he'd
likely have been roped into taking care
of the association and would have ended
up chairman and doing all of that work
meanwhile it took this whole situation
for kiawah's family to actually take a
proper look at what kilwa wanted and how
kilauea values and seize family and
that's before we even discuss the fact
that gone saw his dad for the first time
and immediately fell into apologizing
for his existence
basically which touches on all of those
expectations that tend to run through
families
even not having had that to any strong
extent in the past
gone immediately set to work apologizing
for the loss of his dad's student
someone his dad cared about sure but
seeing the inclination to
apologize just leap out of someone who
has never spoken to his father really
highlights the differences between found
family and the obligations involved with
biological
i guess family that's not to say jing is
bad as god noted
jing said again which means that he took
enough of an interest in his son as a
child to have sent kite to keep an
eye on the kid or at least asked about
him and in fact if memory serves and it
so rarely does but maybe maybe this time
kite turned up out of nowhere because he
was hunting jing right and if he was
hunting jing that means jing was in the
area for kite to have needed to pass and
protect
gone even if gone didn't know his
father's whereabouts it sounds
very much like gene kept an eye on his
son absent doesn't necessarily have to
mean uncaring after all
like he said he's busy but that doesn't
mean he didn't do the work
even the fact that he's willing to fight
everyone in the hall because they're
calling him a bad father but still
manages to make it to the door to say
something soothing to his son
tells us that he's not changing his
behavior on principle the principle
being
that that is who he is but it that he
shows care in his own way
and that last found family situation was
paris on paris don't enjoyed sparring
with lotero so
he wanted to win to prove he could but
he also knew he couldn't do the job
natero did nor did he want to
ultimately despite the disappearing
people and all of the other
secrets and and storylines that have not
been explored
peristoren ceded the task to the person
he knew would enjoy it and give it the
respect it deserved our expectations
were somewhat subverted there again
but not quite paris on simply wanted to
win not to hold power which is very
chaotically hisoka in his own way 146
was a lovely experience of connecting
the dots really and i was surprised to
find it so late in the game
so let's see what the last two episodes
hold but that's not for now and i have
to go watch him
so that's it from me if you enjoyed the
found family trope as much as i do
click here here and here share like
subscribe
tell people have a croissant and i'll
see you
next time